Superman's clerk Kent disguise with the
glasses would have a hundred percent
worked and I'm gonna prove it to you you
know how Superman disguises himself as
Clark Kent just by wearing a pair of
glasses 12 years ago there was a famous
viral video that asked you to count the
number of times a pair of basketballs
were passed between a group of friends
the answer was 15 then came the twist
the video then asks whether you saw the
gorilla what rewind the video there he
is a man walks through the frame wearing
a gorilla suit most people don't notice
them because they're too focused on
Counting the basketball passes this
experiment shows that when you're
focused on one thing you selectively
observe that one thing and nothing else
it all comes down to Observer Bias
that's the tendency for people to notice
what they expect to see rather than
what's actually there what does all of
this have to do with Superman most
people aren't expecting to see Superman
as a nerdy soft-spoken slouching classes
wearing reporter at the Daily Planet so
they don't see Clark Kent as Superman
and you don't have to take my word for
it either Superman actor Henry Cavill
once hung out in broad daylight in Times
Square while wearing a Superman shirt
next to a giant billboard of his face
and no one noticed him that is why I'm
convinced that